zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
deutschland ist heute einen kleinen
schritt gegangen was die rechte von
frauen über die selbstbestimmung am
eigenen körper angeht die usa hingegen
sind einen großen schritt zurückgegangen
der supreme court hat das
abtreibungsrecht gekippt bundesstaaten
können jetzt also abtreibungen verbieten
heißt das vor dem gericht in washington
wurde deutlich wie gespalten das land
ist
abtreibungsgegnerinnen bejubelten den
urteilsspruch enttäuschung und wut
hingegen bei den frauen die für das
recht auf abtreibung
frauen und bürgerrechtsbewegungen
zeigten sich empört konservative
politiker begrüßten hingegen das unter
unsere korrespondentin alexandra harlin
ist für uns vor dem supreme court
alexandra wie sind die reaktionen
also als die entscheidung der richter
des supreme court verkündet wurde brach
ihr lauter jubel aus sie haben sich in
kürzester zeit
abtreibungsgegner aber auch
abtreibungsbefürworter
eingefunden und die die im hintergrund
gerade sehr laut schreien das sind die
befürworter
es ist heute ein historisches eine
historische entscheidung gefallen 50
jahre lang seit
1973 galt ein bundesweites
verfassungsmäßiges recht auf abtreibung
das wurde heute aufgehoben und das heißt
wie du es eben gesagt hast dass jetzt
die bundesstaaten entscheiden können ob
sie abtreibung erlauben ob sie sie
einschränken oder komplett verbieten
kannst du das noch ein bisschen genauer
erklären wir sehen missouri hat schon
reagiert und verbietet als erster
bundesstaat abtreibungen was genau
bedeutet im einzelnen dieses urteil
genau also es gibt 13 staaten 13
bundesstaaten die im vorfeld schon
gesetze erlassen haben weil eben
abzuwarten war dass der supreme court
möglicherweise dieses grundsatzurteil
aufheben wird diese 13 bundesstaaten
haben ihm sogenannte trigger los so
heißen die lassen die treten jetzt in
diesem moment in kraft und darunter sind
auch oklahoma texas tennessee wenn wir
jetzt auf oklahoma zum beispiel gucken
das hat eines der striktesten
abtreibungsgesetze da wird abtreibung
verboten ab dem zeitpunkt der empfängnis
und
als akzeptierte gründe für eine
abtragung gelten dann nur noch
vergewaltigung inzest oder ein grund ein
rationaler grund der immer gelten wird
ist wenn das leben der mutter in gefahr
ist und ich sondern wir schauen mal kurz
hier im netz auf reaktionen die wir auf
twitter schon gefunden haben unter
anderem vom ehemaligen präsidenten
barack obama hat sich schon geäußert
wenn wir hier mal kurz auf den monitor
schalten dann sehen wir barack obama
schreibt hier in einem tweet
heute hat der oberste gerichtshof nicht
nur fast 50 jahre präsident fälle
rückgängig gemacht er hat die
persönliche entscheidung die persönliche
entscheidung die jemand treffen kann den
launen von politikern und ideologen
überlassen und die grundlegenden
freiheiten von millionen von
amerikanerinnen angegriffen und wenn wir
uns gleichzeitig anschauen was donald
trump junior twittert der sohn des
ehemaligen präsidenten der schreibt
traut auf mein vater for what he has
accomplished today ich bin stolz auf
meinen vater für das was er heute
abgeschlossen hat alexandra
welche welche politischen ausmaße hat
diese diese entscheidung gibt es schon
weitere reaktionen gibt es politische
reaktionen
genau also die reaktionen zeigen wie
gespalten das land ist und wie komplex
und
kontrovers das thema
diskutiert wird eine ganz bemerkenswerte
reaktion ist das wohl der vorsitzende
des supreme courts sich kritisch zu der
entscheidung geäußert hatte er hat
angemerkt es hätte nicht sein müssen
dass das supreme court über dieses
grundsatzurteil
versus welt wird es genannt entscheiden
hätte müssen das liegt aber auch daran
die entscheidung dass es gibt neun
richter am supreme court die mehrheit
ist sind konservative richter darunter
drei und um von donald trump
ins amt gebracht
und darauf diesen auf dieser basis kann
man sich das erklär und warum die
richter des supreme court heute so
entschieden haben wir warten auch auf
ein statement des us präsidenten joe
biden will sich in kürze dazu äußern wir
werden das hier live übertragen wenn er
vor die presse tritt und unterdessen
schaue ich hier nochmal in unseren chat
unter anderem bei youtube sehe ich auch
hier ist die meinung sehr gespalten fire
dragon 919 schreibt zb ein trauriger tag
und ein anderer user oder eine userin
ataman apa schreibt endlich zwingt das
gesetz zur solidarität mit dem
ungeborenen kind also auch hier gehen
die meinungen auseinander
alexandra was können denn jetzt frauen
tun die abtreiben wollen und in ihrem
bundesstaat es nicht mehr können
also es anzunehmen dass vielleicht in
rund der hälfte der 50 bundesstaaten das
abtreibungsrecht eingeschränkt wird das
wird millionen frauen betreffen jetzt
ist die frage zum beispiel bundesstaaten
wie kalifornien oder new york die sehr
liberale rechte haben die werden sich
bemühen auch frauen zu unterstützen die
aus anderen bundesstaaten für eine
abtreibung anreisen möchte das ist die
frage aber das könnte natürlich auch
bundesstaaten also konservative
bundesstaaten verbieten
wir haben auch schon festgestellt dass
die nachfrage an abtreibung spielen die
man sich im internet bestellen kann
gestiegen ist auch in mexiko das seit
2021 ein recht liberales
abtreibungsgesetz hat da
wurde auch bekannt dass schon mehrere
frauen aus dem naheliegenden texas
angereist wird
gibt es den chancen dieses urteil noch
zu kippen
dass das wird tatsächlich schwierig also
es gebe möglichkeiten die frage ist aber
wie realistisch sind die also natürlich
könnte der kongress ein entsprechendes
gesetz verabschieden das muss dann aber
durch beide kammern das
repräsentantenhaus und durch den senat
wo die republikaner eine mehrheit haben
es gilt also als unwahrscheinlich
natürlich könnte auch man versuchen die
richter zahl am supreme court zu
vergrößern aber auch das braucht eine
mehrheit und gilt als nicht realistisch
und zu mal dauert das auch eine lange
zeit abtreibung ist ein thema das
derzeit kritisch ist also für viele
frauen wird sich das jetzt erstmal die
lage nicht ändern
vielen dank alexandra hallen für den
moment wir sind nachher wahrscheinlich
noch mal bei dir wenn wir auf die beiden
warten erstmal danke für diese
einschätzung im live vor dem supreme
court in washington danke schön und wir
sprechen hier weiter im stream mit anne
wieczorek sie ist feministin und bekannt
durch ihre tweets zum hashtag aufschrei
frau wieczorek auch für deutschland ist
heute ein besonderer tag was
abtreibungsrecht angeht ich würde aber
gerne erstmal über das sprechen was dort
in den usa heute entschieden wurde ich
sehe hier einen user namens christoph k
der schreibt über youtube langsam kehren
wir als gesellschaft in die geistige
steinzeit zurück würden sie dem
zustimmen
na ja auf jeden fall wieder in noch
verstärkter patriarchale umständen also
das ist definitiv mit den symptomen
dessen was wir weltweit beobachten
können anwender eine rückentwicklung
einer verschärfung von den rechten die
in erster linie marginalisierte menschen
betreffen und das trifft natürlich auch
reproduktive rechte wie eben den zugang
zu einer sicheren und legalen
abtreibungen
ist das für sie ein historisches urteil
in den usa und was zeigt es ihnen über
den weiten weg der frauenrechte der in
den
in den in den usa in den vergangenen
jahren gegangen wurde war das alles
umsonst
das ist hoffentlich nicht jetzt zeigt
nur dass dieser kampf nicht vorbei ist
es zeigt dass diese rechte die uns dann
vielleicht einmal durch irgendein
gericht oder dergleichen durch gesetze
gegeben werden dass sie sehr fragil sind
dass wir die immer wieder erkämpfen
müssen und solange das der fall ist sind
wir dieser nicht sicher also das problem
ist eben wirklich dass das nicht von
vornherein als in dem fall jetzt von
abtreibung sprechen als teil der
medizinischen grundversorgung als
menschenrecht auch betrachtet wird und
das problem haben wir letztendlich auch
in deutschland also das ist kein
universell nur in den usa bestehendes
problem sondern das sehen wir in vielen
westlichen ländern vor allem und
insofern muss das auch im
gesamtzusammenhang letztendlich auch
betrachtet werden was in den usa
passiert was es auch für uns hier
bedeutet eine userin namens anna es
schreibt es gibt oftmals nicht die
richtige aufklärung über verhütung und
sex generell in den usa und jetzt das
tiefstes mitgefühl für alle frauen in
den usa die nicht über ihren eigenen
körper verfügen können ist das aus ihrer
sicht auch ein großes problem wenig
aufklärung wenig möglichkeiten selbst zu
bestimmen über den eigenen körper weil
man einfach zu wenig weiß
das gehört mit dazu definitiv gerade in
den usa ist die sexuelle aufklärung ja
oft auch mitunter gar nicht möglich an
schulen wo sie eigentlich wie bei uns
gesetzlich geregelt sein sollte und da
ist ein sollte und zugang bestehen
sollte aber das ist natürlich nicht der
einzige grund nach verwüstungen kann
schiefgehen keine bildungsmittel sind
die sind wirklich 100 prozent sicher und
auch dann muss es möglich sein zugang
zur abtreibung haben zu können wenn man
dieses kind nicht austragen möchte oder
das potenzielle kind das ist ja teil der
rhetorik das dann immer direkt schon für
ungeborene leben gesprochen wird obwohl
es vielleicht gerade erst zu einer
empfängnis gekommen ist aber was ich
noch sagen wollte was sehr wichtig ist
auch in bezug auf die usa das ist gar
nicht so eine gespaltene entscheidung
wie immer betrachtet wird also der
großteil der menschen ist auch dafür
eigentlich warum werden beizubehalten
also das ist nicht gut über 70 prozent
die eigentlich ja das ist ein gutes
gesetz und das problem jetzt ist vor
allem es beruft ja die entscheidung bei
brocade sagt ja das ist eine private
entscheidung darf der staat nicht
eingreifen
deswegen ist abtreibung ernsten erlaubt
aber auf diesen grundsatz urteil berufen
sich auf andere wie zum beispiel das zur
gleichgeschlechtlichen ehe
zur
zum sex mit von von schwulen männern zum
einvernehmlichen sex wird von vielen
männern und eben auch zur verhütung
zugang zu verhütungsmitteln und diese
sind jetzt auch massiv gefährdet dadurch
dass logie baird gekippt wurde dass es
auch diese gesetze jetzt nicht mehr
geben wird und der entsprechenden zugang
bzw die entsprechenden
gesetzlich kein nicht mehr herrschen
werden und das ist ein riesiges problem
und zeigt wieder wie das noch sehr viel
mehr auch auf andere marginalisierte
gruppen hat sich letztendlich auswirkt
wir werfen mal einen ganz kurzen blick
ins weiße haus denn wir warten ja wie
schon angesprochen auf joe biden der
sich in kürze zu diesem urteil äussern
wird aber wir sehen dass er noch nicht
da ist die kollegen warten und so warten
wir weiter und machen weiter mit ihnen
frau wieczorek dieses historische urteil
in den usa gehen sie davon aus dass das
eine strahlkraft auch auf andere länder
hat
finde ich zuletzt dadurch dass ja auch
die usa involviert ist sein zum beispiel
bei endlos entsprechende programme für
gesundheitsversorgung in anderen ländern
zu fördern
und wenn das jetzt über die welt
sozusagen beeinträchtigt wird während
das damals schon bei donald trump
gesehen da gab es dann schon endlos die
eben ja keine abtreibungen durchführen
durften das wurde dann nicht mehr
finanziell unterstützt und das wird zum
beispiel dann der auswirkung haben und
letztendlich ist es aber auch immer
wieder wichtig wir haben ja zu sehen
dass hier wirklich eine christliche
nationalistische christel
nationalistisches projekt besteht und
das ist nicht nur in den usa das sehen
wir auch global vernetzt das ist
finanziell sehr stark aufgestellt und
das wirkt bei uns auch in europa
nicht zuletzt zum beispiel auch in polen
ganz so stark aber die auswirkungen
sehen wir letztendlich überall also dass
das jetzt für die ein großer meilenstein
ist jetzt wo remake zu haben um die
sozusagen dann auch wieder wind unter
den flügeln bekommen dieses projekt
weiter voranzutreiben
weiter noch mehr geld in entsprechende
kampagnen zu stecken um diese rechte
anzugreifen und weiter abzubauen
das ist sehr deutlich und das wird uns
also das beeinflusst uns letztendlich
auch
werfe man blick auf die argumente der
befürworter denn wir haben ja auch
gerade gesehen es gab auch vor dem
supreme court heute viele frauen die das
auch bejubelt haben dieses urteil
hier schreibt ein user namens gerhard k
punkt zum beispiel am tag an dem in
deutschland ein weiterer schritt auf die
kommerzialisierung der kindstötung
gemacht wird stichwort § 209 10
abschaffung entscheidet sich die älteste
demokratie der welt für das leben ein
sieg für das leben was sagen sie zu den
argumenten der befürworter die dieses
leben eben im körper der mutter aber
eben dieses leben in den vordergrund
stellen
das ist schon mal sehr schwierig weil es
eben wirklich diesen sehr ideologisch
aufgeladene rhetorik jetzt angeht was
was dieser kommentar jetzt sagt und was
wir letztendlich auch in deutschland
immer wieder sehen wenn jetzt wie zum
beispiel zuletzt zu 219 arzt diesen
themen diskutiert wird im bundestag das
problem ist halt dass das leben der
betroffenen person die eben schwanger
ist und darüber entscheiden muss will
ich das jetzt
austragen werde ich das überhaupt will
ich das kann ich das überhaupt
dass das nicht in den vordergrund
gestellt wird und darum sollte es sind
erst wenige gehen und da gehört einfach
ganz klar abtreibungen zur medizinischen
grundversorgung und auch in deutschland
zum beispiel aus aus dem strafgesetzbuch
es gibt ja auch befürworter die sagen
frauen und männer gleichermaßen
sind zu ich sage mal schwierig bei der
verhütung dann ist man halt schwanger
und dann lässt man halt abtreiben und es
gibt tatsächlich ja auch frauen
ärztinnen und ärzte die berichten von
frauen die immer wieder kommen und immer
wieder ab treiben und das mit dem
verhüten aus welchen gründen auch immer
einfach nicht wollen oder nicht auf die
reihe kriegen ist das ein argument dafür
oder dagegen
nein und das ist letztendlich auch der
wirklich minimal anteil also denn wer
zum beispiel bezahlen in deutschland das
anschauen der großteil der frauen die
hier ab treiben die haben bereits kinder
manchmal sogar mehr als 1 und die wissen
sehr wohl was für eine entscheidung
wieder treffen
also das ist dann letztendlich ja dass
wir einfach gesellschaftlich darauf
vertrauen müssen dass diejenige die das
betrifft auch die richtige entscheidung
für sich und ihr leben
letztendlich treffen und ein problem was
jetzt wiederum auch sehr stark in den
usa zu sehen sein wird und da sehen wir
hier letztendlich schon weil obwohl
sowie make-up und faktisch abtreibung
legal war gibt es ja trotzdem schon ganz
viele bundesstaaten in denen abtreibung
extrem eingeschränkt wurde also zuletzt
haben wir wahrscheinlich die meisten
die den das gesetz in texas zum beispiel
mit bekommen also wo dann
sechs wochen
nach nach der schwank nachdem nach der
schwangerschaft so zu sagen dann schon
diese straffrei ist wenn man das
abtreiben lässt das ist ein zeitpunkt wo
die meisten gar nicht wissen dass sie
überhaupt schwanger sind und
letztendlich auch noch das gesetz so
geregelt wurde dass menschen andere
menschen letztendlich verpfeifen können
wenn sie davon wissen dass jemand
abgetrieben hat also wirklich so eine
art kopfgeld system da eingesetzt das
sind wirklich abgründe die die gab es
acht stunden bevor way gekippt wurde und
ich fürchte das wird jetzt nur noch
schlimmer werden dadurch dass ich das
jetzt wirklich bundesweit
beziehungsweise in dem ganzen land dann
auch noch stärker letztendlich
verbreiten darf also mccanns hat ja
schon nach einem nationalen einem
bundesweiten landesweiten
abtreibungsverbot gerufen und das wird
denke ich jetzt auch leider von
republikanischer seite jetzt noch
stärker kommen
wir schauen noch mal ins weiße haus ob
sich dort was tut und donald trump
entschuldigung
joe biden vielleicht schon vor die
kameras tritt das tut er nicht aber wir
können vielleicht noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen der oberste gerichtshof
der usa hat nach fast einem halben
jahrhundert das liberale
abtreibungsrecht in den vereinigten
staaten gekippt das liegt daran dass der
wii gerade schon von frau wieczorek
genannte mehrheitlich konservativ
besetzte supreme court den weg für
strengere abtreibungsgesetze frei
gemacht hat und das bedeutet dass
einzelne bundesstaaten jetzt entscheiden
können abtreibungen zu verbieten 13
haben sich schon im vorfeld juristisch
so aufgestellt dass es ihnen auch heute
das möglich macht das tatsächlich auch
schon umzusetzen und missouri hat als
erster bundesstaat schon abtreibungen
verboten wir warten auf den us
präsidenten der immer wieder auch
versucht hat hier im sinne liberaler
politik ein urteil wie dieses heute zu
verhindern was ihm nicht gelungen ist
und wir sind gespannt wie sein statement
gleich in kürze ausfallen wird während
wir auf den us-präsidenten warten
sprechen wir in deutschland mit der
feministin wieczorek über die lage in
den usa aber auch in deutschland frau
wird zurückkommen wir mal auf 219 hier
in deutschland
das fällt jetzt ein bisschen schwer weil
natürlich das urteil aus den usa alles
überdeckt was heute hier zu feiern war
aus sicht von frauen die das recht am
eigenen körper gefeiert haben und die
abschaffung von 219 a gefeiert haben
aber versuchen wir mal diesen kleinen
fortschritt in deutschland hier
einzuschätzen wie wichtig war die
abschaffung von 219 aus ihrer sicht
ein fortschritt aber es ist eben leider
wirklich ein kleiner fortschritt also
wenn wir uns das gesamtpaket angucken
wie
abtreibung in deutschland geregelt ist
dann ist abtreibung faktisch immer noch
illegal weil es eben im strafgesetzbuch
geregelt ist und 290 dna konnte auch nur
so funktionieren wie er funktioniert hat
weil es eben ja bei abtreibung als
strafbar gilt unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen straffrei ist wie zb
eben die pflicht beratung oder eben
diese drei tage wartezeit aber
das ist am ende wäre uns angucken dass
unsere körperliche selbstbestimmung und
ja im übrigen nicht nur die von frauen
sondern eben von allen menschen
schwangere entschuldigung wenn ich sie
unterbreche dass der us präsident
vor die kameras und wir wollen rein
hören
[Musik]
tja so weit also der us präsident joe
biden zum heute getroffenen urteil des
supreme courts befassen zusammen ein
trauriger tag für das gericht und auch
für das ganze land das recht der frauen
eigene entscheidungen zu treffen das vor
50 jahren mit einem urteil erkämpft
wurde ist damit heute vom tisch der
präsident sagt das leben und die
gesundheit der amerikanischen frauen
steht auf dem spiel und zum ende hin hat
er noch einmal darauf hingewiesen warum
das so ist nämlich weil sein vorgänger
im amt donald trump drei konservative
richter im supreme court installiert hat
mit deren mehrheit heute diese
entscheidung getroffen werden konnte wir
sind hier bei zdf heute live freuen uns
nach wie vor über ihre meinungen und
kommentare und auch fragen
ich
würde vorschlagen wir nehmen an dieser
stelle unsere gesprächspartnerin wieder
mit ins boot dazu wir freuen uns dass
sie dabei ist anna wieczorek feministin
und bekannt durch ihre tweets zum
hashtag aufschrei frau wie zurück sie
haben den us präsidenten gehört er hat
gesagt das leben und die gesundheit der
amerikanischen frauen steht auf dem
spiel es ist ein bisschen tragisch mit
anzusehen wie herr präsident der für
eine andere politik steht eine solche
entscheidung jetzt kommentieren muss wie
ging es ihnen dabei
ja das ist ja wie so oft so wo man
einfach sieht dass dieses system
letztendlich sehr kaputt ist was da in
den usa vorherrscht und letztendlich für
diese wichtige entscheidungen zu sorgen
hat und ich glaube es ist auch umso
wichtiger zu erwähnen dass er
letztendlich auch die die es am meisten
treffen wird das jetzt dieses wichtige
grundsatzurteil gekippt worden ist das
ist in erster linie arme frauen das sind
in erster linie frauen auch color
schwarze frauen und diejenigen die sag
ich mal entsprechend finanziell
aufgestellt sind und keine weiteren
hürden wir haben irgendwie mal in
anderen bundesstaats zu gehen oder
vielleicht sogar ein anderes land die
werden weiterhin auch problemlos
abtreibungen durchführen können also das
trifft eben insbesondere diejenigen jaja
die sowieso schon gesellschaftlich
extrem marginalisiert sind und ja das
zeigt einfach die grausamkeit dieser
entscheidung und dessen was dahinter
steht wenn die leute sagen sie sind
angeblich pro life also ich finde das
sehr wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass es
hier eben nicht darum geht welche leben
zu schützen sondern hier werden ganz
klar leben angegriffen leben vielleicht
sogar zerstört letztendlich wird es
immer abtreibung geben egal wie die
gesetzeslage irgendwo in welchem land
auch immer ist die frage ist halt nur
sind sie illegal zugänglich sind sie
sicher sind sie vielleicht sogar
kostenlos verfügbar wir haben das ja in
spanien zuletzt gesehen die ein gesetz
beschlossen haben eben für reproduktive
gerechtigkeit wo ganz klar dass
garantiert wurde das eben zum beispiel
krankenhäuser
sorgen müssen dass das personal auch
abbrüche durchführt und sich nicht
rausreden durch irgendwelche
ja ich kann das aufkommen eines glaubens
oder ähnliches nicht machen also das
klar gesagt wird hier ist eine
versorgungslage abgedeckt und dass es
einem so großen land wie den usa nicht
gegeben ist auch schon vor wie wait das
ist wirklich mehr als zeugnis dafür dass
wir eben längst nicht so weit sind mit
den frauenrechten und sämtlichen
menschenrechten wie das sonst immer
gerne so behauptet wird viel zu tun
hatte wie zurück vielen dank dass sie
bei uns im stream dabei waren dankeschön
der vor einem halben jahrhundert haben
die frauen überall in den usa gefeiert
dass es ein abtreibungsrecht gibt dass
ihnen die möglichkeit gibt über ihren
eigenen körper selbst zu bestimmen heute
nun sind viele viele dieser frauen
frustriert wütend und sie haben viele
aktivistinnen in den usa davon
gesprochen dass es ein heißer sommer
werden wird denn diese entscheidung und
alles was damit zu tun hat dass es nicht
zu ende mit dem heutigen tag das ist
klar vielen dank für ihre fragen und
kommentare danke fürs zuschauen und
mitmachen bis bald